[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're on bumble tinder or hinge you
become a customer choice it can be hard
to settle on one or two or it's just a
numbers game you keep swiping to the
right until the app closes on itself
don't ask about it it might be a
personal thing prop bets are sexy and
there are a lot of options welcome to a
special props edition of the be our
bedding show presented by the Caesars
Palace sports book I'm your host cabby
retros and this is my excellent co-host
and betting expert Kelly Stewart the
Super Bowl is a DeGeneres dream you have
one game 1 million betting options and
it's always a numbers game one of the
biggest reasons the Super Bowl is the
most bet event each year is because a
prop bet so
we're do a little prop one-on-one
session for you guys here now prop bet
is a wager on a player or event that may
not directly affect the game's final
outcome now don't forget guys you cannot
parlay profits also try not to buy into
the small sample sizes and recency
biases of certain players now you need
to know when you're paying a premium for
certain big-name guys patrick mahomes
and always practice good bankroll
management oh by the way when this line
is wrapped around here at the Caesars
Palace maybe save everyone some time and
use the rotation number to the left of
your prop bets listen Kelly before I was
old enough to learn rock-paper-scissors
flipping a coin was the way that we
determined who go first in tic-tac-toe
or connect for and failing falling for
this line heads I win tails you lose
caused me a lot of anguish and it took
me a while to learn that lesson
Caesars odds have the coin toss at heads
minus one or two tails
- warnings why do people love this
particular profit so much well before I
get into that now if you want to bet the
coin flip and your buddy likes the other
side just bet each other and save
yourself the two cents of juice but why
I like to bet this one is because who
doesn't love winning right out of the
gate now you can't bet the national
anthem time here in the United States so
the next best thing the coin toss you
get a winner or a loser right out of the
gate now I like heads here
I know tails has hit five of the last
six times but we're due right
not exactly how this works cuz each
independent coin flip is just that so
make sure you guys bet this one for fun
only if you're keeping score though
through 53 Super Bowls the coin is
landed on tails 28 times and heads 25
times okay let's get to the good stuff
Ken city's reputation is scary they've
got the Legion of zoom basically a track
team on the offensive side of the ball
and an outstanding defensive team in San
Francisco's reputation and his pro ball
tight end George Carroll looks more like
SummerSlam than Super Bowl Kelly which
players offer the most value
George Kittel Iowa tied in that's
exactly what he looks like Gaby speaking
of tight ends no tight end has caught
the first TD since LJ Smith and back in
2004 Super Bowl 39 so there's lots of
big names on this first board here and
rightfully so these are probably going
to be one of the guys that scores the
first touchdown but you guys know me I
love some of the longer shots Matt Breda
is one of the longer shots that Caesar's
took here at the sports book six figures
at two hundred to one this one opened up
it so they dropped this one tremendously
enough liability for that guy for them
but I'm gonna go with a wide receiver
wide wide receiver has scored six of the
last ten the first touchdown I'm going
with Emmanuel Sanders at 18 to 1 this is
his third Superbowl my man has been here
before and will get open for Jimmy G so
I'm gonna take a shot with him at 18 to
1
speaking of scoring that first TD that
puts you in conversation to win Super
Bowl MVP now here are some of the MVP
favorites we got both quarterbacks 9 of
the last 13 Super Bowl MVPs and that's
why they're priced accordingly so but
this one's gonna plan a little bit
differently for me
we have Raheem Mozart we have George
Kittel Damian Williams also some really
good value here if one of those guys
goes off on the defensive side of the
ball mr. Boesel over here Russians looks
a little appealing at twenty to one a
couple other guys at twenty to one two
of the best receivers in the game yes
Travis Kelce is a receiver I don't care
what anybody says
and also Tyree kill but this game is
gonna be played out a little bit
differently in my mind
and I've thought it Begley looks like
Super Bowl 50 where the Panthers with a
slight favorite against the best defense
in the Bronco all right do you Johnny oh
yeah my favorite player in the NFL mr.
Vaughn Miller and who is a von Miller
this year Richard Sherman interesting
interesting totally I love Richard
Sherman to win MVPs thirty to one now
we're talking about not only his style
of play is gonna get him that award but
also the price at thirty to one is
really appealing I do think he's gonna
be on Tyree kill very well and also
because he's a captain he is that
backbone of this defense if the Niners
win this game I think he has a real shot
to win MVP
speaking of captains of Defense's we saw
Ray Lewis win Super Bowl MVP a few years
ago and he was the captain of that
vaulted Baltimore Ravens defense to
paraphrase the late great Christopher
Wallace you're nobody till somebody
names a Super Bowl profit after you and
that is that a real lyric yes from
biggie smalls welcome to Genesis classic
record and I'm proud to announce that
bleacher report has it's very own Super
Bowl cup debo Samuels rushing yards here
it is on the Caesars Palace website
rushing yards to the line right now is
over/under 14 and a half Kells what do
you think about this week you know this
was interesting because it opened at 15
and a half Canada now it's been bet down
which I agree with you got to get juice
- 125 if you want about the under I do
lean towards the enter here now Chad
Johnson big fan of Chad and obviously
his expert analysis always on the show
now he mentioned what a threat debo is
in the slot and I have no doubt in my
mind that debo is gonna have a big game
but I don't think it's gonna come from
the backfield I know he's gotten some a
few touches back there over the last
coming weeks but again that goes back to
the recency bias that I warned you guys
about so be really cautious here again I
look for him to have a great game just
probably more in the slot position got
it in less than a month heavyweights
Deontay Wilder and Tyson Fury will fight
in a rematch right here in Las Vegas now
the Super Bowl heavyweight matchup we
can't wait to see is Patrick Mahal's
versus Jimmy Garoppolo these are the
props will start with Patrick my arms
passing yards over/under three or three
and a half Willie throw an interception
yes plus 120 no minus 140 Kelly where
are you leaning on these two props I
gotta say this first and foremost
Patrick well Holmes is good damn good
and I don't want to bet against him per
se but at a point in time I mentioned
you're gonna be paying a premium for
some of the bigger names who's the
biggest name on this stage Patrick
mahomes this one has already been been
up throughout the week and I'm just
gonna hang tight I see it only getting
higher
so come Sunday I'm gonna be on the under
when he faces the best defense he's seen
all year and will he throw an
interception listen Patrick plays clean
games but he is prone to mistakes at
certain points in time and that plus 120
looks really nice in now in baseball
pitchers are famously held to like a
pitch count and they rarely pitch past
the sixth inning shout out to patch my
home senior was a pitcher for many years
in MLB now after throwing only eight
passes and the NFC Championship game
against the Packers I thought that Jimmy
Garoppolo might be on like a pass count
he's only thrown 27 passes in the last
two games and this is an interesting
proper I hear Willie throw an
interception yes minus 140 no plus 120
savvy that's a really good way to put it
because I do think Kyle Shannon and has
really limited Jimmy G since he threw
that interception in the Vikings game
that's right and it makes sense why are
you gonna ask your man to do something
that maybe he's not capable of doing all
we need him to do is manage the game and
be mistake-free just why I like no plus
120 known for his stylish game day fits
Travis Kelce is also patch of mahomes is
number one target on offense
here's his receiving prop over/under
seventy six and a half yards were you
leaning on this one as we've been souls
for years what does Bill Belichick do in
these big games he takes out their best
player I don't think that the San
Francisco 49ers can take out Patrick
mahomes so their next option to try to
take out Travis Kelce now we've talked
about throughout there's a lot of praise
for a caution in yes it is now we've
talked about the last couple weeks how
do you limit the best players here this
is gonna be tough but Tyreke Hill said
they can't stop all of us mm-hmm they
got to stop a couple of these guys and I
think Travis Kelce is gonna be their
number one stop I like the Under
seventy six and a half receiving yards
for mr. Kelsey on Sunday and if you get
a cosign from Dwayne Johnson you're
doing well in life now the people's
tight end is what it's what he tweeted
about a month ago
speaking about George kid ole and this
is his prophet another interesting one
longest reception over under twenty five
and a half yards are you gonna play this
one I don't love this one I'm gonna put
that out there first and I do think
Kittel is gonna have a really good game
here but I do really anticipate that
Chiefs defense coming to play as you
know Frank Clark has been chirping a lot
lately and with drop will be limited as
we spoke about and I don't see kiddo
having a huge pass though I do think
that he is gonna have a good game I
think it's gonna be a lot more dink and
dunk type passes to my tight end over
here got you they say that timing is
everything and that proverb certainly
applies to one betting on the Super Bowl
in this week's act expert analysis bill
Kraken burger shares a strategy for
timing the market when betting on props
though Frankenberger from crack wings
dot-com and the crack wins out I know
everyone is excited to bet on the big
game but I'm here to tell you a few ways
the sharp guys like myself will be
betting I don't look to wager I'm one of
the two teams that are going to win I
look at the proposition that's the
individual player props are where the
value of is I bet the overs early and I
bet on the funders closer towards game
time when all the public money is in and
the sports books are forced to over move
an example of this bet is George piddle
I played them over sixty seven and a
half receiving yards yesterday I will be
betting Patrick mahomes under 37 passing
attempts closer to kickoff remember you
guys your allegiance shouldn't be on any
one team it should be to your bankroll
thanks to Bill Kraken burger of crack
winds calm Kelley would he make
themselves advice Phil is just super
great and everything he said is
absolutely spot-on us he mentioned his
kid ol bet is now up to 73 and a half
here at Caesars so now the only way you
could probably look is under there but
here are some props and I plan on
investing in come Sunday one of the best
running backs we've heard about over the
last three weeks Raheem most dirt
rushing yards seventy three and a half
longest rush eighteen yards now I said
over the last couple weeks is why
there's a big time recency bias and that
means both numbers are inflated the
narrative I've heard all week every
single TV and radio persons can't wait
to tell me how a Kansas City can't stop
the run yeah I don't know Kansas City
sure stopped one of the best running
backs in the game Derek Henry in that
AFC championship game and I think that
is exactly what's gonna happen in the
Super Bowl I like both unders
Tyree kill total receptions over 5 - 145
now this one's funny I made a funny
tweet about how he was making fun of his
quarterbacks voice and I said dead under
5 receptions but then I started to get
an actual grasp on this and what Chad
Johnson talked about and how Tyreke Hill
is going to be teamed up against Richard
Sherman I do not believe that Tyreke is
gonna go over I think the bookmakers did
a good job on this number so we get a
push no harm no foul but if he happens
to bobble one we go under that plus 125
looks really nice will there be a
defensive or special team CD all I've
been doing is hyping up both defensive
players and teams this entire show yes
plus 220 looks mighty enticing I'm gonna
take a shot on it here cabby this one
always gives me this specific project
our social team traveled to Houston
Texas for Game one of the World Series
to meet a local legend who wagered are
reported eight figures on the Astros to
win the World Series Jim mcinvale aka
mattress Mac lost millions when
Washington won in seven games so he gave
me Las Vegas to spend some time with
Kelly and the social team laying down
some money on a prop betting snake draft
will there be enough
[Laughter]
Matt did you learn what an octopus is
today let's see okay can I explain
explain to the people or knock you so
I'm an octopus is I'm gonna give them a
formal definition of Caesars basically I
think you're gonna score eight points
and in one possession so an octopus is
the player scoring 8 points in one drive
a player has to score the touch on that
same player has to score the two-point
conversion Mack I need a full breakdown
well they're gonna score a touchdown and
then the losses talk going back no sir
most who's gonna score Jeff Dunham
you'll get two point conversion yes sir
retail royalty right here at Caesar's
Palace thank you Jim mcinvale aka
mattress Mack for joining the social
team in the props bedding draft you can
watch the full video on social
@br underscore bedding and vote for who
you think will win my money is always on
JP Morgan Kelly over here to my right
well Cathy I took it a little more
seriously than those guys did because I
really want to win so those are my
favorite prop that's in order but if one
of those long shots hits it's game over
for me but one of my picks that was my
best bet in the snake Draft is my best
bet for this show as I mentioned all
show long prop bets are about how you
anticipate a games going and while I
haven't gone to the window on the side
or the toilet just yet I have told you
guys all show along I expect that
defense on both sides to show up
especially in the red zone and that is
why I like both of these guys over three
and a half field goals made what's a
little 105 here at Caesar's Palace
Robbie Gould garrison bucker
come to play just for me we hit the over
and I don't care what else happens
throughout the rest of the Super Bowl
now let's recap all of my Super Bowl
profits these are listed in order of
confidence of how many units I'd
recommend you bet on each I have a three
unit play on the / field goals made as
my best bet but I also really liked
Tyreke he'll receptions under five plus
125 now some fun bets here we have the
coin toss landing on heads
Patrick mahomes passing yards under 303
and a half and he's gonna throw an
interception but no interception from
his
Jimmy G George Kendall longest reception
under Raheem Mozart rushing yards under
and his longest Rush under 18 yards and
yes there will be a specialty touchdown
or defensive shot job plus 220 thank you
for joining us on this special props
edition of the VR betting show it has
been presented by the Caesars Palace
sports book make sure you're following
along on social @br underscore betting
to track all of our Super Bowl
activities on Friday Kathleen I will
join the BR social team and betting
every single profit if Caesars has to
offer going against everything I ever
believed in Cathy give me a lot of fun
and after it's Kelly and I will be
hosting another game day game show live
at 8:00 p.m. Pacific time right here at
Caesars Palace in on Saturday night our
social team will be camping out right
here on this stage at the sports where
are you gonna be subbing bye
no I have to be here like 5:00 a.m. on
Super Bowl Sunday and then the producers
are forcing me to watch the game with
you guys okay fine it's gonna be a great
time we're gonna be back here Sunday
2:00 p.m. eastern eleven a m-- pacific
breaking down the big game and don't
forget to check back with your favorite
halftime duo JLo and Shakira no cabbie
you and I we're gonna be live at
halftime with first-half analysis and
second half picks good luck on all your
profits and see you guys on Super Bowl
Sunday
[Music]